[Música]
bueno muy buenas tardes
mi llegada a los desastres estuvo llena
de casualidades y decisiones como suele
suceder comparte importante en las cosas
de la vida adulta
[Música]
resulta que en el 2009 yo trabajaba para
la fundación techo cuando ocurrió el
terremoto de cinchona como en las
primeras horas teníamos tan poquita
información de lo que estaba sucediendo
y había además había sido un sismo
bastante fuerte y todos estábamos muy
asustados
decidimos ese mismo día ir a buscar
información directamente con las
comunidades afectadas así que esta tarde
estuvimos conversando con las personas
de fraijanes poasito
y al regreso de la gira le dije a mi
compañera de trabajo
yo voy a dedicarme a esto ella se me
quedó viendo un poco confundida me dice
como a esto y yo sí a esto a los
desastres yo la verdad que este día no
puedo recordar mucho más allá de
personas asustadas grietas en las calles
tiempos imposibilitaban el ingreso a
muchos sectores y las réplicas que no
paramos de sentir lo que sí puedo sentir
como si fuera ayer es la sensación de
estar en el lugar correcto
así que aquí estoy siendo una educadora
física ex nadadora psicóloga máster en
gestión de riesgo una combinación
bastante confusa pero que ha resultado
ser maravillosa y terminar resumiendo en
hola soy de esas astróloga
y créanme a nadie se me olvida esa
palabra y la verdad que es igual de
importante tener una desastrosa cabecera
como una doctora de cabecera
y este recorrido ha estado lleno de
mucho trabajo en equipo aprendizajes
retos empezando por el hecho que es un
campo históricamente de hombres y en
estos casi diez años he tenido la
oportunidad de trabajar con gobiernos
locales organismos internacionales
universidades y comunidades y estos
proyectos van desde estar en un albergue
brindando atención psicosocial a las
personas afectadas para facilitar los
procesos de recuperación con un enfoque
de salud mental hasta trabajar con el
sector productivo que tiene sus cosechas
en zonas de riesgo para ver cómo hacemos
acciones de mitigación y en el caso de
que el desastre suceda poder recuperar
la economía lo más rápido posible y por
qué les vengo a contar todo esto porque
costa rica es un país multiamenaza es
decir tenemos 112 volcanes 5 de ellos
activos el territorio se encuentra sobre
dos micro dos micro placas una placa
tectónica y además por nuestra ubicación
geográfica somos propensos a huracanes
ondas tropicales tormentas
eso debemos sumarle la falta de
ordenamiento territorial y los efectos
del cambio climático que cada vez con
mayor frecuencia nos pasan la factura en
resumen a nivel global somos el quinto
país con mayor exposición al riesgo el
quinto
[Música]
justamente por eso es tan importante
el rol que podemos tener como ciudadanos
y ciudadanas ya que las acciones tienen
que venir desde los distintos niveles y
para entender ese rol tan importante que
tenemos en el tema de los desastres
tenemos que quitarnos una idea a la
cabeza y es esta se acuerdan cuando los
libros escolares decían desastres
naturales y todos los medios de
comunicación dice desastres naturales
cuando sucede alguna emergencia alguna
situación vamos a imaginarnos lo
siguiente
resulta que el ime n nos dice que hay
una onda tropical sobre el territorio
son esos días que llueve mucho que todo
nos da presa salir de la casa está
lloviendo mucho mucho mucho se escucha
alguna rayería lejana poco a poco los
retumbos se van acercando y en
escuchamos un retumbo muy cerca se
escucha el retumbo y resulta que fue un
rayo que cayó sobre un árbol cayó sobre
un árbol el árbol se empieza a quemar
algunas personas se dan cuenta llamar al
911 911 manda la unidad de bomberos pero
cuando la unidad se quiere acercar el
lugar no pasa porque hay carros
parqueados al otro lado de la vía
suena la sirena suena la sirena algunas
personas salen de los carros las sirenas
sigue sonando otras personas ni se han
enterado finalmente el camión de
bomberos logra pasar llega al sitio y
resulta que ya no sólo se está quemando
el árbol sino tres casas
les parece que eso es natural
[Música]
muy bien y es que es importantísimo
entender que la construcción de lugares
seguros es una responsabilidad
compartida
el creer que nunca nos va a pasar nada
destruye procesos y mata personas y
aunque suene exagerado son las primas
son las pequeñas acciones las que hacen
una diferencia entre la vida y la muerte
porque el puente que se queda durante
una emergencia lo podemos reconstruir
pero las vidas no es posible
recuperarlas y los japoneses que son
buenísimos en esto porque les ha pasado
todo emergencias nucleares tsunamis
sismos han desarrollado una metodología
donde hablan de tres tipos de ayuda
autoayuda ayuda mutua y la ayuda
institucional
si precisamente esa ayuda que creemos
que debería ser la primera en llegar por
las características propias de la
emergencia tardé un tiempo en llegar a
los lugares por eso es tan importante
que estemos organizados en nuestras
casas y con nuestros vecinos porque
siempre creemos que las cosas les pasan
a los otros pero resulta que esos otros
a veces se convierten nosotros
por ejemplo ustedes sabían que la
principal causa las inundaciones urbanas
son los residuos sólidos
si esas inundaciones que hacen que
ensayó se colapse que dejan carros
atrapados que nos hacen llegar tarde
reuniones suceden precisamente porque
alguien dejó una bolsa de residuos en el
lugar incorrecto y nadie hizo nada para
cambiarlo y si eso todo lo sentimos muy
lejano porque ya estamos llegando a las
tardes de diciembre de verano llueve
menos pensemos en un sismo cuántos de
ustedes tienen un maletín de emergencias
en su casa un maletín que sea fácil de
agarrar con un foco con medicamentos de
uso común si hay personas diabéticas
hipertensas o si hay niños y niñas
pañales o si tenemos mascotas
tenemos una correa cerca de la puerta o
alimentos para ellos y tenemos que salir
rápidamente del lugar
o algo tan sencillo como las llaves de
la casa donde tienen las llaves de la
casa
si tuvieran que salir rápido por un
sismo por un incendio podrían encontrar
fácilmente las llaves de la casa
así que los invito a usar esa
solidaridad que nos dejó otro la
impotencia de nate este temor a los
sismos para hacer de la crisis una
oportunidad para construir entre todos
un país más seguro porque es justamente
las cosas que hacemos a diario las que
se las que hacen la diferencia al
momento de una emergencia hagamos de la
seguridad un hábito
[Música]
[Aplausos]